adam x asks in a recent interview lou
stated that he just finished a trip to
washington and that quote-unquote crap
is going to hit the fan soon can he
elaborate on this at all what does that
mean
yeah um
there's a lot happening there's a lot
happening
um
the conversation has definitely shifted
and more information is becoming
available
on a almost on a regular basis
um
[Music]
i'm not prepared to go into any type of
specifics right now um it will become
evident
uh i've if there's one thing that's
hopefully been clear to people every
time i say the conversation's gonna
shift and and new stuff comes out it it
does uh i i don't say that because the
last thing i want to do is over promise
and under deliver i'd rather under
promise and over deliver
um but
but the conversation is occurring um
and
that's about all i can say right now for
that because it would require other
people to step in and comment that i'm
not i do not i'm not
in a privileged situation where i can
share their
their comments or opinions on it um sure
um what do what do you think i don't i
got to be careful i say
no i i
you know
lou and i go on podcasts because we want
to we want to communicate we want to be
involved in a conversation
but especially in this instance we need
people to understand that when we have
something to say that's when we're going
to have something to say we're not in
the in the podcast business and we're
not we're not professional interviewers
and and frankly every time we do
podcasts it takes us away from the work
that makes the progress
now that doesn't and a lot of people
have wanted us you know they say we want
you guys to get more involved we need we
need answers well we don't have the
answers that you desire
we have we have
information that we have accrued we have
relationships we have accrued we have
things we're trying to change we have a
world we're trying to change but at this
point
it's becoming less and less
valuable for us to spend our time doing
these things when there's so much more
that we can be doing on in what people
call behind the scenes outside of
ufology away from from the public eye of
this
and i just want to say that people have
to ask themselves what they want
do they want to be entertained or do
they want change
it it is truly that simple because
we don't have and this is not a
this is not me striking out but we don't
have time to entertain folks we don't
have time a lot of these questions
i'm not i understand they're interesting
questions they're questions i ask myself
but but for the time we have today
they're not and and for the work that we
work on they're not valuable they're not
additive at the moment to the work that
we're doing they end up muddying the
water a great deal because what we're
dipping into is a lot of questions about
various books and beliefs and ideas and
ufology
not what's on the record as evidentiary
value
and i i really want to stop i want to
stop asking or answering questions about
what do you think of so-and-so's book
where he had an idea
i don't think much of it it's his idea
it's and i could say that for a hundred
other folks
because it's
it's not the we lou and i can't afford
to sit around the campfire and have a
just speculative conversation because
frankly people assign meaning to our
opinions that's i'm tired of that
and so i i want to see a place where we
can have a conversation that is additive
i know people want to know what we think
it's not important what sean cahill
thinks
okay it's not important what my opinions
are because i think my opinions are
garbage
it's important what your opinions are at
home i um i try to distance myself from
from from that current as much as
possible
um you know there's so much speculation
in this field and everybody pushes it
off as fact
it's one of the reasons why you just
don't engage
you know i'm getting to the point i'll
tell you right now
i'm going to start doing a lot less
you're going to notice a huge i'm going
to do a few more to finish up my
obligations but
i'm not doing these much longer
this is it
reason is because
i'm not sure i'm being very helpful at
this point um i'm helpful behind the
scenes but
being like this in public all it does is
serve to divide people when really my
intent was to unite people bring them
together
but the the
i don't have time to focus
on the he said she said [ __ ] i don't
i don't care about it never have i never
will and you know you you you want more
of the same then go back to the last 70
years of [ __ ] because that's what
people think you are they think you're
full of [ __ ] because you talk about
wacky stuff you got no evidence and
because he said he wrote a book on
something who you know
what does that mean means nothing you
got to show evidence you got you got to
you know where the bonafides where are
the videos where's the reports where's
the the the discussions to congress and
the classified briefings
they're nowhere because i haven't seen
them on the hill when i'm there i
haven't seen them in dc when i'm going
by the pentagon or anywhere else they're
not those meetings so for me to come out
and when i you know historically i've
always tried to share information to be
as transparent as possible
but i think we're reaching a point now
where
i think people have what they need kurt
i i don't think they need lou elizondo
coming in and feeding them
information anymore